hello I'm Charles Cantor and I'm
speaking to you from the beautiful
polish city of Gdansk where I'm here to
help inaugurate a new European framework
programme on genomics and proteomics and
today I'm going to talk to you about
genomics I'm going to focus mostly on
cancer and the thrust of my topic is how
to discover and use non-invasive
biomarkers to monitor the status of the
tumor or the status of therapy so we
like to use the plate assets as
biomarkers because they perform really
well in a clinical diagnostic setting
and we like to use these non-invasively
for reasons that are pretty obvious so
our choices to get samples of nucleic
acids non-invasively are somewhat
restricted blood you're in a few other
places but blood is best for two reasons
blood communicates with almost every
distant site in the body so in principle
if events happen they may release
molecules that can be seen in the blood
and we have a tremendously well
developed infrastructure to obtain blood
from patients distributed purified
samples from it and so so let's think
about in a sample of blood where might
DNA come from almost all the DNA is
inside nucleated blood cells
once those are set aside what remains is
very very dilute so if there are cells
from distant places tumor cells fetal
cells and pregnancy then there'll be DNA
in those cells but typically there's
about one or two for himself per CC of
blood compared with hundred thousand or
a million nucleated cells so the
cellular components of DNA in blood from
distant sites are really too diluted to
use in addition to cellular DNA there's
about ten times as much vesicular DNA
but that means 10 molecules and that's
still too little to work with
fortunately there's free DNA that's 10
times more abundant still and typically
free DNA from distant site might
represent about a hundred molecules of
any genomic sequence so it's a very tiny
amount but it's enough to work with in
the typical situation the host
contributes a background of about ten
times as many DNA molecules so you can
see we're going to have two challenges
we have to detect very few molecules and
we have significant background in the
past when people try to isolate say cell
free DNA from plasma they didn't realize
that this DNA were so rare and as it
turns out that it's very low molecular
weight and they didn't realize that it
was essential to avoid the breakage of
hosts blood cells which will drown out
your signal with background well we've
learned a lot in the past two years and
that enables the kinds of studies that
i'm going to show you
so to motivate this let me challenge you
to think about a funny question what's
the common feature in three very
different clinical situations
Alzheimer's disease cancer and pregnancy
that common feature is some bad so in
all those three situations and many
other clinical situations there is
programmed cell death and during
apoptosis the cellular DNA is cut into
nucleosome sized pieces so that's about
150 base pairs and these pieces then
enter the circulation if the pieces from
a distant site a tumor a fetus a dying
brain if the pieces have different DNA
molecules then the DNA molecules that
are found in the white blood cell
background then by looking at these
differences we can infer the properties
of a distant site without touching it in
the case of pregnancy and cancer there
are sequence differences between the
fetus and the mother between the tumor
and the host in other situations like
neurodegenerative disease or
cardiovascular disease there are no
sequence differences between brain cells
or heart cells and blood cells but there
are epigenetic differences okay so by
looking at either sequence or
epigenetics we can learn properties of a
distant site without touching it the
challenge is that we have so few
molecules this leads to a fundamental
physical problem called stochastic noise
if on average you have very few
molecules and you take a sample then
because of statistical fluctuations it's
impossible to in a single sample get a
precise
representation of the true abundance and
this stochastic noise scale is the
square root of the average number of
molecules so if I have a hundred
molecules my standard deviation will be
plus or minus 10 and if I use a range of
three standard deviations the
certificate that's plus or minus 30
which means i have almost no ability to
qualify if i have five molecules or 10
molecules obviously i can't quantify and
i might miss a sequence altogether so
called a real dropout so this is a
fundamental problem and we need to solve
this problem to work with cell-free DNA
and plasma and there are basically two
strategies for trying to overcome
stochastic noise the standard approach
is to repeat the measurement but our
measurements require 10 cc's of blood
and we consume the entire sample to
detect our target so it's not possible
to sample a hundred times you can't take
a medium of blood from the patient so we
need a different strategy we need to
find a large set of different but
biologically equivalent markers
different DNA sequences so that instead
of averaging from sample from aliquot to
ellicott in a single measurement we can
combine the results from multiple
sequences and you'll see how we do that
okay now in trying to look at cell free
DNA basically you need a platform that's
very sensitive and among the currently
available platforms
a three are widely used you can do PCR
you can do DNA mass spectrometry which
is essentially pcr detected by mass
spectrometry or you can be in any
sequences different DNA sequences second
generation DNA sequencing and the choice
among these platforms is determined by
cost by error rate but honestly mostly
by too good so if a single locus
sufficed you can use pcr but in the
problems i'm going to show you a single
locus does not suffice either because
we're trying to suppress the classic
noise or because we have to measure many
low side at once to be sure we've
captured the clinically relevant
information okay and so will use either
DNA mass spectrometry or DNA sequencing
and i'm going to show you next a
non-invasive prenatal diagnostics which
uses DNA sequencing and then i'll show
you non invasive cancer diagnostics
which currently uses mostly DNA mass
spectrometry okay non-invasive prenatal
testing has been commercially available
for two years now this year alone in the
US between Sequenom and other companies
offering commercial tests we will have
studied at least 300,000 women looking
for common fetal at authorities we only
look at the high-risk population and in
the u.s. there are 750,000 high-risk
pregnancies each year so in the second
year of clinical adoption we will have
tested almost half of the available
market and it said that this is the
fastest uptake
I'm a new clinical procedure since the
invention of penicillin so what I'm
going to do is to show you the
principles and then show you some
results of this procedure oops sorry
okay so we're using peripheral blood we
take a 10cc draw that yields four cc's
of plasma and we're going to analyze
that plasmid DNA by random shotgun
sequencing as you'll see and the process
is actually pretty simple but there's a
problem in an average pregnant woman
thirteen percent of the DNA comes from
the fetus and eighty-seven percent comes
from the mother but in individual
pregnant women there's a range of a
factor of 20 and if the mother has only
a few percent fetal DNA there's too much
stochastic noise to make the measurement
so we have to have a way independently
of guaranteeing that there is sufficient
fetal DNA to get above a statistical
threshold and in the commercial tests
that we provide that threshold is
currently four percent if we fall back
below that threshold essentially the
fetus becomes invisible and so in a
pregnancy when we test we will conclude
that the fetus is female because the
mother's female and we'll conclude that
the fetus is normal because the mother
is normal so that's not good if the
fetus is actually a male we can use y
chromosomal sequences to ensure that
there's enough to DNA in the sample but
of course half of all fetuses are female
so we need a different approach and for
those fetuses we currently
use of epigenetics so we searched the
whole genome and found sites which
consistently are methylated in the fetus
and unmethylated in the mother these are
imprinted genes which are silenced
during fetal development by methylation
and we look for sites that have that
property and in addition they fell in
sequences that are recognized by
restriction enzymes that are inhibited
by methylation so what we do is we take
the mixture of a fetal and maternal DNA
as shown here so we saw it with the
mixture of fetal and maternal DNA we
cleave it with a cocktail of restriction
enzymes and what happens is that the
fetal DNA remains intact but the
maternal DNA is cleaved and we now have
only pure fetal DNA so when we quantify
that it tells us the number of fetal
molecules so here's what that looks like
for one imprinted locus one methylation
sensitive locus in women who are not
pregnant there are no molecules of
methylated DNA detected even earlier
than a weeks in a pregnant woman we see
methylated sequences and after eight
weeks when we would actually perform
non-invasive prenatal Diagnostics up we
have a nice robust signal but two
cautions to see it's tremendously
different from patient to patient and
here the average number of fetal
specific sequences in our sample is only
140 so we're definitely in the domain of
stochastic notice all right so I'm going
to show you a cartoon that illustrates
the principle of how we quantify the
abundance of
in the mother's blood here I've color
coded the DNA fragment so that the red
ones are from the fetus and the blue
ones are from the mother and okay so
this is an average pregnancy so thirteen
percent of the fragments are from the
fetus what we're going to do is sequence
starting basically from single molecules
amplified and then read reread 36 paces
from one end of these fragments and if
the read matches a human genome assembly
we can assign that fragment to a
chromosome if the read doesn't match we
discard it and in practice we make about
12 million reads and this allows us to
build up a histogram of the abundance of
each of the different chromosomes in the
mothers but our large chromosome like
chromosome 1 will generate a lot of
fragments a small chromosome will
generate very few and we know from
independent experiments that the whole
genome both maternal and fetal are
represented more or less evenly in the
mother's blood however if the fetus is
unemployed so for example if it has an
extra copy of chromosome then the fetal
contribution from that chromosome will
lead to him and imbalance in counts so
if the fetus has three copies of
chromosome 21 they'll be extra counts
from chromosome 21 it's a small effect
because if the fetal DNA is only ten
percent of the whole and we're going
from two copies of chromosome 21 to
three then it's a five percent effect so
that be able to measure that very
confident
in the presence of stochastic noise
takes this rather elaborate procedure
but let me show you what that looks like
first I'm going to show you results from
that clinical trial that led to the
launch of this test commercially so this
trial was managed by women's and infants
hospital and Rhode Island it involved
about 2,000 patients 27 centers
worldwide all of these patients for
women who had high-risk pregnancies that
had volunteered to undergo invasive
testing either amniocentesis or
chorionic villus sampling and before the
invasive test we took our 10 cc's of
blood we then looked at the relative
abundance of chromosomes and what I'm
plotting here our results for the three
most common an employee's trisomy 13 13
and 21 and what I'm showing on the
vertical scale is a statistical measure
of whether the representation is normal
or abnormal and one in plotting
horizontally is the percentage of fetal
DNA and what you can see is that some of
these some of these pregnancies
obviously have over representation of
chromosome 21 or 13 or 18 I want you to
notice that we don't look at women with
less than four percent fetal DNA and
that in general it is a pretty good
correlation between the amount of fetal
DNA and the strength of the statistical
deviation exactly as there should be so
since these women all had invasive tests
subsequent to the blood draw we could
use the results of the invasive test as
a gold standard
and compare the non-invasive test and we
could basically get a pretty good
picture of how accurately we were and
this summarizes the results on the
common trisomies and also on the X and Y
chromosome an employee's determination
of gender if someone wants that and also
results from twins and triplets and the
bottom line is that the results are not
perfect but they're close to that error
rates are very very tiny results are far
better than ninety-nine percent accurate
so this was a research project a
clinical trial subsequently we
transferred this test into our clear lab
of clinical diagnostic service lab and
they refined it they improved the sample
preparation that improved the methods of
analyzing the data they treat the
sequencing procedures and today the
results are so good that it no longer
made sense to use conventional invasive
testing as the gold standard because in
fact the sequencing is more accurate so
this shows results are for chromosome 21
on about a hundred thousand pregnancies
it's the same kind of plot the
statistics of statistical significance
of a deviation from normality here you
can see very very tight Gaussian
distribution of that statistical
parameter for normal pregnancies and
have a large number of triceps so this
test works extremely well but again
it is not perfect if we look over here
at the very low fuel fractions although
our cutoff is four percent will make an
occasional error if it's a pregnancy or
five or six percent we could raise the
cut off but then there'd be too many
samples that are uninformative with a
four percent cut off we can actually
make the definitive call on 99 percent
of the samples which is extremely good
okay so we get false negatives in
samples which don't have enough fetal
DNA we get false positives for a variety
of interesting biological reasons
there's a phenomenon called confined for
sample mosaicism in which the fetus is
normal but the placenta is try Sonic and
since most of the circulating DNA from
the fetus actually originates from the
fetal portion of the placenta we'll make
a Miss Cole another example is what's
called the vanishing twin you start with
a twin pregnancy one is normal one is an
employed the unemployed twin dies this
is quite common and then you have a
placenta that represents a unemployed
twin but the other twin that remains is
normal so we make errors like that and
occasionally we see other things that at
first were confusing so here is some
results for a pregnancy very high
fraction of fetal DNA it appeared it
looked like a positive z-score means
that you have an extra copy of a
chromosome and a negative z-score means
that you are missing a chromosome and it
looked like this fetus was and an extra
copy of 21 was missing 13 and 18 in fact
this has very
to do with them he does this pregnant
woman also had metastatic carcinoma and
we were sampling DNA from the tumor as
well as the fetus here's another case in
this case it looked like 2113 with
deficient 18 was present in excess these
results was so surprising we repeated
them and as you can see the replicate is
excellent but once again this is not the
pregnancy this pregnant woman also has
an invasive angiosarcoma okay so you'll
see in a few minutes when we transition
to cancer that it's the same principle
just not as mature we also see other
things at the current sequencing depth
if there are sub chromosomal but large
insertions or deletions we see them here
for example is the abundance of counts
across most of the genome and you can
see the just part of the short arm of
chromosome 18 is elevated where will we
see something like this we don't know if
it's the mother or the fetus unless it's
a known syndrome and the mother is clear
that syndrome we can we can assess that
by going back and looking at maternal
buffy coat up but this leads to a very
amusing and interesting situation
because we see in roughly one percent of
all these pregnancies we see chromosome
abnormalities that in some cases are
well understood like angelman syndrome
and in other cases are just mysteries in
fact if we're willing to sequence more
deeply we can see anything and
everything and three years ago within it
slowly sequence the entire genome of an
unborn fetus at horrendous expense
admittedly up but it can be done two
years later several groups reproduce
these results
at much less cost and in a few years
it's probably going to become practical
to do this on every pregnancy if you
wish but suffice it to say this raises
some pretty human de settle issues you
may not want to know the whole genome
sequence of your unborn child okay well
we're going to switch now more in line
with the subject of this meeting from
non-invasive prenatal diagnostics to non
invasive cancer diagnostics and we're
going to use mass spectrometry for that
for several reasons in cancer we are
mostly interested in looking at genome
abnormalities that drive are the
properties of the tumor so cancers have
unstable genomes they have a mutator
phenotype so the genome is going to hell
and there are millions of abnormalities
in the genome of a cancer cell but most
of that is annoys what we're really
interested in predominantly is somatic
mutations that lead to the
aggressiveness and the particular
properties imagine a tumor and the
number of those somatic mutations is
finite and it can be managed still by
DNA mass spectrometry the advantage of
the in a mass spectrometry over
sequencing is throughput we can measure
hundreds of samples a day with one
instrument instead of just a few if we
had to do DNA sequencing so you may not
be familiar with DNA mass spectrometry
and I want to just briefly show you what
the properties of this tool are our
first let me show you the context in
which we're currently trying to use it
oops wait a minute sorry okay
we want to focus on somatic mutations
that make trimmer sensitive or resistant
to drugs for a given patient will
normally be able to start with the
biopsy and but then we want to
transition from a biopsy to measurements
and plasma and just fixing a little
quicker on the street thank you okay
okay so dearly mass spectrometry we use
TCR to amplify simultaneously many low
sign and a single microtiter plate well
we have to do this because we want to
look at many potential AQHA gene
mutation simultaneously and once again
we have to consume the whole sample to
make the measurement the pcr-amplified
are too long to fly at a mass
spectrometer so we subdivide these by a
subsequent sequencing reaction with DNA
mass spectrometry we only look at intact
DNA molecules that samples are not
allowed to fragment in mass spectrometer
and so if I have a sample of DNA after
pcr it consists of only four bases and
they have very different molecular
weight so we can predict from the
sequence the expected molecular weight
of any DNA fragment and that means that
we can design asses in software and
their work and it means that we can
analyze mass spectra from look-up tables
so this is very very simple just to make
sure you see what the process is here's
a schematic picture for a single by
allylic locus if it's heterozygous when
we do PCR we make two amplicons the
different sequence by a single
nucleotide and when we then sample this
sequence different by placing a sequence
of
next to it and extend by a single race
will make this blue fragment that ends
in G by copying the cereal and will make
the green fragment that ends in c by
copying the g allele and when we fly
just the sequencing products in the mass
spectrometer will see two peaks and if
they're equally abundant they'll have
equal area and affect the area of these
peaks represents concentration with a
precision of one or two percent so this
is a very accurate way of detecting much
of sequence but also abundance but we do
this not just on one focus we do this on
many low side 00 01 10 20 40 so we know
currently about 700 somatic mutations
that define the properties of cancer and
depending on the tissue and type of the
cancer our knowledge of important
mutations ranges from very completely to
barely scratching the surface and I'll
show you an example from breast cancer
because it's kind of average of our
current understanding so this is a study
done using DNA mass spectrometry at MD
Anderson hospital and published last
year they were looking at women with
breast cancer these are invasive
measurements fine needle aspirate and
they looked at 267 samples with methods
that had a sensitivity that will prob
was promptly around five percent okay
and at that sensitivity they could see
having tested probably 500 mutations
they could see 37 different mutations in
this cohort and forty percent of the
world in this cohort had one or more of
these somatic oncogene mutations of
the most common are in pik3ca now what's
amazing is that every one of these
mutations is clinically actionable so
for this lucky forty percent of breast
cancer patients that have one or more of
these mutations it's possible to choose
an optimal therapy but this is still
invasive and so now we want to go from
invasive to non-invasive and to do that
we have to raise the sensitivity so in a
typical biopsy of a solid tumor a
somatic mutation can present at a few
percent or up to fifty percent let's say
because a biopsy of a timber is really a
mixture of normal cells and tumor cells
there when a tumor cell dies it's a DNA
is diluted by normal cell free DNA in
the host and so instead of needing a
sensitivity of five or ten percent we
need a sensitivity that's much higher
and i'm going to show you that the met
the kind of method to choose to achieve
that that higher sensitivity so our
problem in detecting let's say a
one-percent mutation or a half percent
mutation in the background of a vast
excess of wild-type is that when we
perform our sequencing reaction the
wild-type template consumes the
sequencing primer and we may not be left
with enough sequencing primer to detect
so to solve this problem what we do is
we omit the substrate that it allows the
sequencing primer to extend
on the wild-type template we add only
substrate that allows the sequencing
primer to extend on the mutant template
and therefore we essentially eliminate
the wild-type peak from the mass
spectrum and now we only see the mutant
p and if we watch that peak in a set of
frostbite sample you can see that even
at the less than 1% mutant we see a very
distinct kick in the mass spectra that
identifies the moon we call this
technique saber SI DVR and this version
of it is a little tricky but in a few
minutes i'll show you another version
that's more robust let me pause just to
say that i noticed people are sending in
questions and I'll there were the
questions are at the end of the
presentation but I don't want to
interrupt to do it right now okay so
dupes alright so here is a study from
Japan in which they used this very
sensitive saber procedure to monitor
tumor specific DNA in plasma the
patience of lung cancer patients and
these patients were chosen because they
had activating mutations in egfr
tyrosine kinase and they were being
treated with tyrosine kinase inhibitors
the problem with using these very
effective but specific drugs is that the
mutator phenotype of the cancer alley
provokes the the creation of mutants
which are less sensitive or insensitive
to the drug and
with the tyrosine kinase inhibitors of
egfr the most common resistance mutation
is t790m this does not eliminate the
utility of the drug but it compromises
its effectiveness so this group looked
at about 70 patients being treated we're
tyrosine kinase inhibitors and if you
look just on the left of this slide the
green curve represents patients that did
not have this compromising mutation and
the red curve shows patients that do
have the t790m mutation and you can see
that the prognosis of the patients with
the t790m mutation is considerably worse
so this is useful it's non-invasive so
you can employ it over and over again
but it's a very limited study next I
want to show you results from Johan de
Bono's lavatory in London these results
did not use the Sabre tool they just
used conventional DNA mass spectrometry
so their sensitivity use less five or
ten percent but it's a much bigger study
these patients are all pays on clinical
trial patients they have very advanced
disease they have a large tumor burden
and as you'll see many of them have
abundant of cancer specific DNA in their
plasma so this slide compares the
average DNA concentration that we see in
pregnant women with what debono sees in
healthy volunteers and his late stage
cancer patients and you can see that
when he compared healthy volunteers and
late-stage cancer patients there's about
a factor of eight elevation in total DNA
in plasma this
suggest but does not prove that most of
that DNA is tumor-specific before I
leave this slide let me just mention we
don't think the difference between
pregnant women and healthy volunteers is
significant because the methods used to
quantify the total DNA were quite
different but now let's focus in on this
difference that Debono sees between
healthy volunteers and cancer patients
so this breaks it down DNA abundance
total DNA abundance and blood up in
colorectal cancer breast etc all the way
to healthy volunteers and you can see
that in almost every kind of cancer
there's significantly more DNA and blood
than in healthy volunteers you can also
see from patient to patient a huge range
in DNA concentration again this is total
DNA concentration now if you combine all
these results and you can ask the
question does the total DNA
concentration in blood is that a
parameter with any clinical value and it
turns out it turns out that it is very
valuable so patients with low total DNA
blood concentrations have a very good
prognosis and patients with high DNA
concentrations in plasma have a very
poor prognosis and since this is just
total DNA in blood these measurements
could have been made in 1960 if people
knew not to break the hotels and new to
capture these small DNA fragments and
these results have never been repeated
in the other site so in addition to just
looking at that totally made
concentration we can ask
if we have a biopsy and plasma from the
same patient do we see the same somatic
mutations and the answer thus far is
about half the ton and in half a dozen
other studies that have been published
in the past year it's always the same
answer roughly half the time and there
are three reasons for this most of the
methods in use are not sensitive enough
and so in tumor samples or plasma
samples then with less than a few
percent towards specific DNA those
signals are lost second stochastic noise
in patients who have very few molecules
then there's a little drop down and but
finally there's a biological situation
here remember that in plasma we're
looking at DNA from cells have dot that
have died recently because plasma DNA
has a half-life of about 15 minutes
where is in a sample of the tumor we're
looking at mostly tumor cells that are
alive so it's not surprising that
there's a lot of discordant if we use
more sensitive methods then we can
eliminate the problems of missing low
abundance and wheels but we still will
have to deal with sarcastic noise and
we'll have to deal with biology but this
clearly argue that to push the field
further along we need methods that are a
lot more sensitive and I'm going to show
you a method that we're about to launch
commercially which I think answers this
need so it uses the same principle just
as before we don't provide a substrate
that allows the wild-type sequence to be
read so the only in sequence that's red
as the miracle sequence but we supply
that substrate with a capture tag about
them so that after primer extension we
can capture the mutant sequences with
streptavidin coded magnetic beads and
then in the mass spectrum there is no
wild-type allele there's only a mutant
allele and this approach can be
multiplexed and so we can look at many
mutations at the same time so here's
what this looks like for some spike in
sample at 1% half a percent 0% mutant
the red dots are capture controls to
prove this DNA there and you can see
that we have no trouble at all detecting
half a percent and there clearly is very
little background so this method has a
sensitivity that's close to one part per
thousand and think of it if you have a
thousand molecules and only one of them
is a tumor specific sequence you
couldn't use a method with the
sensitivity any higher even if you had
it because there wouldn't be a molecule
to detect where this shows a clinical
sample in which there's actually a
archival paraffin-embedded sample it
Reese is an activating egfr mutant
present at a high abundance and in one
sample a very tiny amount of mutant
t790m EG of our sequence and you can see
that it's it's it's quite visible this
looks like a very good tool we've
practiced it now on eight thousand
different mutants have had this truth
table very correct answers in blue or
incorrect answers and red show that
while not perfect it's method is
tremendously good at and is very robust
very easy to use okay
we have a tool that can be employed on
plasma of cancer patients and this will
be commercially available we expect by
the end of the year and it covers 26
different activating our kitchen
mutations 24 of those are shown here and
and those of you familiar with some of
these notations will realize that this
is going to be useful for sure for colon
cancer lung cancer some breast cancer is
melanoma and so on so this is where r at
now this is detection but as I said at
the beginning of the talk we're working
in the domain where we can't quantify
and that's a pity as I'm about to show
you so if we could quantify then we
would have a way of assessing the clone
allottee of tumors and we can do this on
biopsies where are there aren't enough
molecules so that quantification is
impossible so if I have a biopsy it's a
mixture of normal cells and term results
and if all the tumor cells are identical
and they have more than one driver
somatic mutation then those mutations
should occur at the same allele
frequency because the mutation frequency
is just the percentage of tumor cells
and let's test this on a series of lung
cancer samples so patient number 88 this
results from Japan of two different
driver mutations same allele frequency
looks like oil cooler patient 81 again
two different driver mutations but same
allele frequency clone tumor patient 25
this mutation is present in most of the
cells these two in very few cell clearly
not clone here
another case oops patient 471 to driver
mutations same allele frequency total
tumor patient 4072 driver mutations very
different allele frequencies not follow
so why this is important if you have a
clonal hinter you're dealing with one
disease and it's possible that amount of
therapy would be effective but if you
have a non clonal tumor it's a very
unlikely that you'll be able to monitor
the patient effectively so you'll be
able to treat the patient effectively
with just a single drug okay now so it's
frustrating at the present time we can
detect things but we can't quantify
things because of sarcastic noise and to
be able to quantify things we have to
use the trick that I described at the
beginning of the talk we have to a great
results from multiple markers and there
just are unlikely to be enough
informative of somatic mutations to do
this so we need another approach and
that approach is to use epigenetics just
as we used it in pregnancy to make sure
that we had enough fetal DNA we had to
make a quantitative measurement so we
can also use methylated sequences from
that our tumor-specific if we have
enough of them to form the signature
that we that will be statistically
useful and this paper that I'm going to
summarize was published two years ago
and used DNA mass spectrometry to look
at methylation of after bisulfite
treatment in breast cancer patients and
let me show you first just this one
marker this is one of the bracketing it
was
is a sample of normal breast tissue and
you can see that this marker is mostly
unmethylated there's some methylation
that it's low in a pure sample of tumor
this locus is almost entirely methylated
and in blood from this patient it's
almost entirely mentholated so this
tells you that this patient has breast
cancer and it tells you that most of the
DNA in the blood of this particular
patient comes from the tumor but we have
they had not just one but quite a few
different markers here are as a set of
heat map from eight markers on on
normals and and tumor of carrying women
again desert blood measurements and so
you can see there's pretty good contrast
and clearly you will gain in statistical
confidence if you combine results from
multiple markers there are various ways
of doing that and and in this work they
use the principal component analysis so
here is the first several principal
component of the differences in
methylation between red breast cancer
patients and blue normal again these are
measurements in blood and you can see
while it's not perfect there are a few
outliers there's pretty good
discrimination and this is is not
limited to only eight markers one could
combine many more and it's not limited
to pure methylation alone we could
combine methylation and somatic
mutations so to summarize looking at
plasma DNA in pregnant women is a very
successful commercial value last night
test being performed on hundreds of
thousands of women a year now looking at
the same type of plasma specific markers
in cancer patients
it's just beginning it's a research tool
but I think we can be pretty optimistic
that we'll begin to see widespread use
in the clinic within the next few years
and with that I want to thank you for
being such a patient audience and let's
see if I can handle the questions by
clicking on this button okay so so the
first question has to do with skin
biopsies of leukemia cancer patients
it's it's a subject I've never heard
about before and I'm really not sure if
it's useful but i would consider any
biopsy to be invasive and the question
was is this method invasive it might be
useful but i know nothing about it so
let me just say don't know
okay how do we do this let's see you
feel more question oh the questions is
always the hardest part of this answer
is missing no questions available for
display well I'll give you a couple
minutes to ask me some questions we'll
see if any questions come in oh do you
usually get enough cell-free DNA
sequencing can I use whole genome
amplification to generate cell-free DNA
for my downstream sequencing okay so
here I don't understand this but um I
don't like cold genome amplification
intersect the sports quantitative
features so you can do it but but I
recommend against it
okay we're still waiting for any more
questions okay I guess maybe there are
no more question how this is waiting
okay let's see them okay so I'm being
asked that the idea is to replace
biopsies in the follow-up and the answer
is absolutely yes that's what we want to
do no no no follow-up biopsies strange
about okay so the question is how
reliable is this what is the evidence of
the answer is too early to tell but
preliminary results the rating curve
okay is this going to become the
standard of care is the question and the
answer is yes I think it's going to
become the standard of care there's been
almost 10 publications this year from
all over the world showing proof of
concept and now we just need to refine
the methods and do our studies on large
enough numbers of patients to have
statistical significance okay i think
i'd like to thank you I think we're
going to I don't see any more questions
and I just remind you that this lecture
is eligible for a CME credit so if you
want those please look at this line and
that's how you arrange to get credit